mathematical equations can be quite
intimidating if you don't know how to
read them but they don't need to be it's
possible to learn how to make sense of
them even if you don't know much algebra
so if when you see an equation it looks
like a strange alien language this video
is for you the first rule is you need to
find out where these things called
variables are a mathematical equation
describes a relationship between things
the most common form is something equals
something else these letters are the
variables and as stand-ins for numbers
you can put any number into them but the
equation fix is what the other numbers
can be for example y equals x means that
the numbers in Y and X have to be the
same but in y equals 2x the number in Y
has to be double whatever the number in
X is the best way to visualize this is
with a graph when you do this each
variable in your equation gets an axis
and the line on your graph shows the
allowed pairs of values for your
equation the other thing you get in
equations are constants and you have to
keep an eye out for constants because
they look like variables they are
written with a letter but actually
they're just a single number a famous
one is pi but in science you get many
others so how do you know which letters
or symbols are constants or variables
well you don't you have to rely on the
person writing the equation to tell you
what all of the bits mean practically
when you use equations in science you
have the numbers to put in all of the
variables apart from one and that's the
one you're trying to work out so you
plug in all the numbers and find out
what the last variable should be let's
look at an example of an equation and
how I'd go about reading it this is
Newton's law of universal gravitation
which looks at the force of gravity
between two masses first thing you do is
work out what all of the letters mean F
is the gravitational force that you're
working out m1 and m2 are the masses of
the two bodies G is the gravitational
constant and R is the distance between
the masses
now you work out which letters are
variables and which ones are constants
this formula has just got one constant G
which is a tiny little number now you
basically know how to use this formula
if you have the masses of any two
objects and the distance between them
you can play
in the numbers and calculate the force
of gravity between them so the force of
gravity between an apple and an orange
is about the weight of a grain of pollen
very very small when you plug numbers in
and solve the equation you have to know
what order to do things in and this is
the next step that you need to work out
after you've identified the variables
and constants knowing what order you do
the mathematical operations in an
equation helps you get your head around
them and there's some rules about how
it's done any variables that are just
next to each other are multiplied with
each other and you do these first at the
same time you do any divisions but only
if it's a single number divided by
another number and then you do the
additions and subtractions if you've got
a division but there's an addition or
subtraction at the top or bottom you
need to make sure these are done first
before you can do the division
and finally anything in brackets goes
before anything outside of the brackets
there are more rules but this covers you
in most situations when you come across
an equation in a book or video you're
probably not gonna start putting actual
numbers into it but running through what
you would do if you have the numbers
it's a really useful way to get your
head around the equation in these
examples I've mostly used normal letters
but many equations also use Greek
letters I think this is why equations
look so weird to people because they're
unfamiliar with all these strange
symbols but you should think of them
just the same as normal letters they can
be used to represent constants or
variables so they're just the same
you also get other notations like
subscripts and these are all basically
used as labels to identify different
constants or variables other notation
has specific mathematical meanings and I
can't cover everything in this video but
if you're ever confused about what
something means I encourage you to look
it up as they normally end up being
simpler than you think but also I've
made a handy cheat sheet which I've put
in the description below so you can also
check that out now here are some of the
other more common weird things that
you'll see you're all familiar with
multiplication division adding and
subtracting these are all things called
mathematical operations but they're not
the only ones and here are some of the
more common ones that you'll see this
big Greek epsilon is a sum operation
what it means is that you take this
thing and you repeatedly add it to
itself but put in different numbers each
time this is the number that you start
at and this is the number that you end
that it also means that this variable
has to be an integer variable which
means that it can only take on whole
numbers 0 1 2 3 4 no numbers in between
so whenever you see a sum just imagine
this thing as a whole series of things
being added together but each having a
different value similar to a sum is an
integral which really needs a graph to
explain it it's basically a way of
finding the area underneath a line
that's defined here like a sum it's got
a beginning and an end although these
can go from minus infinity to infinity
so you might see that written sometimes
too
and finally related to integration is
differentiation which looks like this
and it's an operation that looks at how
the steepness of a line changes
the gradient of a line so when you have
things like d-y-by-dx they're looking at
the gradients of lines that's just a
quick look at integration and
differentiation these make up calculus
but that needs a whole video in itself
to explain properly I put them here just
so you don't freak out when you see them
so those are the basics of how to read
mathematical equations step 1 find the
variables and constants and what each
one represents step to work out what all
the weird mathematical operations are
and step three work out what order you'd
solve the equation in if you put in the
numbers if you want more info check out
this cheat sheet I've put together with
all of the different Greek letters and
most of the more common mathematical
operations check it out in the link in
the description below
if you enjoyed this video and other
fantastic resources the sponsor of this
video brilliant org there's no better
way to learn than by solving puzzles
yourself no brilliant you learn through
active problem-solving they have
fantastic introductions to mathematics
like patterns and variables shown here
and what I love about them is that
they're visual and so help you build up
an intuition for mathematics and you're
not just memorizing formulas or learning
sums it's a lot of fun and I really
recommend you giving it a try just go to
brilliant org slash do s or click on the
link in the description below and if you
like my stuff consider subscribing and
thank you to all of my supporters on
patreon your contributions really help
me make this channel viable see you in a
month for a new video